bueno los demócratas como bien decís han
estado involucrados en guerras
internacionales y creo que él la marca
de bailén va a ser de una presidencia en
la administración no que no persigue el
aislamiento de la escena internacional
va a buscar recuperar la reputación de
eeuu
mucha de ella perdida durante la
administración trump va a tratar de
tender nuevos lazos con aliados
históricos y va a tratar de contribuir a
la paz mundial contribuir a la lucha
global contra la pandemia
y va a tratar de encontrar algo de
liderazgo en la lucha contra el cambio
climático todas estas
opciones de políticas no nos llevan a
conflictos pero baile no deja de ser un
político un animal político con lo cual
es y surgiera algún conflicto
internacional
después de ver que una administración
vaivén intervendría en forma militar
creo que va a tratar de evitarlo a toda
costa pero la presidencia de eeuu salvo
raras excepciones en general tiene la
opción militar en la mesa
isabella y que podemos esperar de la
relación con china que fue el país
blanco de todo tipo de críticas y es uno
de los países de los cuales más se alejó
eeuu en este cuatrienio en esta última
administración pero que es una pieza
fundamental en la economía en el
comercio internacional y eeuu por más
que quiera retomar un liderazgo a nivel
comercial y a nivel internacional no
puede dejar de lado a china
no y creo que una administración baiden
va a tratar de entender la sosa china
hay áreas en donde eeuu y china pueden
cooperar por ejemplo en el área del
cambio climático de hecho china ha
asumido un poco el liderazgo dejado
abandonado por estados unidos bajo trump
en esa área de la política internacional
y creo que podríamos esperar ver algún
acercamiento en
en coordinación y en cooperación
climática ambiental probablemente haya
un intento por parte de la
administración baiden de acercar a china
a la mesa negociadora sobre temas
comerciales y creo que como la
administración demócrata anterior la de
la presidencia de obama
un presidente bailén va a tratar de
estaré entre
y un tono duro con respecto a
las violaciones de derechos humanos por
parte del gobierno chino un tono duro
con respecto a lo que se ha espionaje y
de lo que se ha violación a acuerdos
comerciales y un tono conciliador una
estrategia conciliadora para que no se
cierre la puerta
de importantísimo socio comercial
económico y nuevo líder mundial